2021 has certainly been an interesting
year for playstation while we've had
some tremendous highs and some
extremely low lows not to mention the
continuing pandemic it certainly can't
be denied that 2021 has been a unique
first year for the playstation 5.
but there's no time to sit back and
reflect because we've got a whole new
year of exciting games to look forward
to playing on our television stand's
strangest looking item so here is our
list for the most anticipated
playstation games of 2022 and beyond
before we get started keep in mind that
this list is for playstation exclusives
so while we're excited about games like
tiny tina's wonderland or whatever that
final fantasy origin game ends up being
we're saving them for a different list
so get out of here suicide squad kills
the justice league go on get go shoo
shoo i promise we still love you
really
why don't you just mail me the bullet
babylon's fall an online action game
from platinumgames and near producer
yusuke saito babylon's fall isn't what
we were expecting the initial teasers
didn't suggest it would be online for
example but the medieval fantasy setting
and flashy combat both look like they'll
deliver it's also relatively new
territory for platinum which is best
known for single-player action games
like bayonetta and near automata i feel
like a
celebrity in this town
though it still seems to be playing to
the studio's hack and slash strengths
babylon's fall will be available across
playstation 4 playstation 5 and pc
final fantasy vii remake part two okay
i'll admit it 2020's final fantasy 7
remake was the first and only final
fantasy game that i've ever beaten but i
think that speaks to the unique
strengths of both the story and
strategic real-time gameplay of the
long-awaited remake as well as how
adorable cloud looked in that dress
because who can deny that but the
original final fantasy 7 was a massive
game and rather than remake the entire
thing at once square enix opted to
release final fantasy 7 remake in
smaller chapters it's unclear when the
game's next chapter will be out possibly
next year but given some of the
revelations at the end of the first part
it appears it could expand or even twist
the original final fantasy 7 story into
new directions making it one of the most
anticipated upcoming playstation games
there's still so much to be done
final fantasy 16. speaking of final
fantasy a return to a more medieval and
fantasy based setting after the modern
final fantasy xv the upcoming final
fantasy 16 looks like it would lean
heavily and intentionally into some of
the tropes of the genre i mean its
setting is literally described as quote
a land blessed in the light of the
mother crystals for crying out loud
however it looks like it's planning to
build on this with a complex world made
of several different factions and
characters and with the power of the
playstation 5 it aims to be one of the
most stunning games released on the
system we'll also have more
action-oriented combat mechanics once
again and it appears the designer of
devil may cry 5 is serving as the battle
director on the project which should
give everyone confidence
4 spoken a new console exclusive action
adventure game from square enix for
spoken sees protagonist frey holland
transported from our world into a
fantasy realm called atheia where she's
given the power to soar through the air
and cast powerful spells it kinda looks
like a cross between the movement in a
game like marvel spider-man with a much
more magical moveset and given the
fidelity of the trailers and the high
speed action we've seen thus far it
makes sense that the game will only be
available on playstation 5 and pc but
square enix and studioluminous
productions is certainly hoping for the
game to be more than a tech demo for the
system with uncharted amy hennig working
on the game alongside story lead and
star wars rogue one writer gary witta
but we'll have to see if it lives up to
those high bars in 2022
ghostwire tokyo ghostware tokyo is one
of the most exciting upcoming games for
playstation 5 as it's a completely new
experience for studio tango gameworks
the company now owned by microsoft but
honoring an earlier timed exclusivity
agreement developed both the evil within
games previously which while certainly
not for everyone were always uh
interesting
let's go with interesting sometimes too
interesting
yet ghostwire is not a survival horror
game but a paranormal action adventure
with spooky elements played from a first
person perspective with a combat flow
that resembles something like dishonored
it remains to be seen if that combat can
mesh with investigating supernatural
occurrences but tango gameworks has a
knack for world building and has already
shown great improvement since the
original the evil within launched
the world rests on the precipice
transformation
god of war ragnarok okay so we probably
hit the biggest dog game on this list if
you're anything like me you can't wait
to jump back into playing the demigod of
big dad energy the 2018 soft reboot for
god of war which continued the story of
the franchise but radically overhauled
the gameplay was one of the best games
for playstation 4 and sony santa monica
studios follow-up looks to match that
high bar we've only seen a glimpse of
gameplay thus far which will continue
the brutal feel compared to the earlier
games and kratos's son atreus will also
continue to play a major role will
kratos be able to defeat thor the god of
thunder or will the once disgraced
demigod finally be destroyed okay
probably not but we won't know for sure
until the game releases in 2022 on
playstation 4 and playstation 5. but you
know as long as i get to hear daddy
kratos yell boy i don't really care what
else happens
gran turismo 7. not content to let
xbox's forza horizon series get all the
attention gran turismo will be back in
2022. the series has for the most part
stuck to what it has done best over the
years highly realistic racing on tracks
and that's not changing with gran
turismo 7 but it will be getting some
big enhancements to help it feel like a
modern racing simulator that can compete
with the forza series such as a much
more complex time and weather system and
you'll be able to tweak your cars right
down to the tiniest of changes the
campaign mode will also return and will
send you all over the world for a
diverse selection of races as long as
you can you know unlike me stay on the
road
knights of the old republic remake it's
honestly kind of shocking that the
remake of bioware's fan favorite star
wars rpg knights of the old republic
which originally came out exclusively on
xbox back in 2003 will be a timed
playstation 5 exclusive but here we are
the original kotor is considered by many
to be one of the best star wars games of
all time so this remake has big big
shoes to fill set long before the events
of the phantom menace the game has
players exploring the galaxy as the sith
try to take down the republic and as a
result it'll be interesting to see if
this remake will change elements of the
story to better fit with disney's star
wars timeline considering their recent
the high republic series regardless
though asper media is an established
star wars developer already having put
out the recent ports of star wars jedi
knight 2 jedi outcast and star wars
republic commando so here's to hoping
the knights of the old republic remake
can live up to the hype and rekindle the
spirit of the original that fans loved
so much
marvel's spider-man 2. after years of
waiting for a spider-man game that could
finally match the inexplicably good
movie tie-in game spider-man 2 insomniac
games finally delivered with 2018
spider-man and it's equally amazing
mid-cool spider-man miles morales a full
sequel marvel spider-man 2 is now in the
works for a planned 2023 release and it
looks to take the series in a slightly
darker direction it will include both
peter parker and miles morales and the
ps5 exclusive game will feature venom as
one of its villains though sadly with
distinctly less tom hardy i will let you
eat everybody
i promise you can expect lots of
high-flying web swinging and ridiculous
visual fidelity but if we're being
honest i think we're all just hoping for
another suit that lets you keep at least
one cat in the backpack
stray speaking of cats
[Music]
stray is one of the most exciting games
coming exclusively to playstation and
not just because you spend the entire
game staring at the cutest of kitties
yes you are yes you are
excuse me um playing as a cat trying to
survive in a hostile world with clear
cyberpunk influences stray will finally
let you know what it's like to be a cat
that means knocking stuff off of ledges
sneaking and working your way into
hiding spots and using your kitty wits
to keep yourself out of danger straight
doesn't have a firm release date yet so
you may need to take a few cat naps
before it arrives but it will be a
glorious day when it does
uncharted legacy of thieves collection
in what is clearly intended to be a
tie-in with the
let's just say interestingly cast
uncharted film coming out next year
what naughty dog is bringing back its
famous action adventure series with a
new compilation bundle for playstation
5. uncharted legacy of thieves
collection bundles together uncharted 4
a thief's end and uncharted the lost
legacy with remastered graphics and an
improved frame rate on sony's new
console those games already looked and
performed fantastically on playstation 4
but we're still waiting to see how they
are improved upon for playstation 5. at
the very least it should help make the
wait for a possible uncharted 5 a little
easier to manage and if you want my
recommendation the lost legacy is easily
one of the best games in the entire
franchise and not just because you get
to play as the horribly
under-appreciated claudia black though
that certainly doesn't hurt you know
that treasure hunting is not a good gig
for the risk of us
wolverine wolverine which is in
development at insomniac games is
perhaps the upcoming playstation game we
know the least about it appears to be
early days for the project which was
announced via a cg trailer earlier this
fall presumably though it will be an
action-adventure game like insomniac's
other superhero game though likely with
a greater emphasis on wolverine's claws
and healing factor it also probably
promises to be a much more brutal game
than spider-man given you know
that it's wolverine yet we're going to
have to wait and see because we don't
actually know when we'll get our first
look at gameplay or a better
understanding of what the game will be
horizon forbidden west of course you
knew this game had to be on our list
somewhere the long-awaited sequel to
guerilla's hit game horizon zero dawn
was planned to be released in 2021 but
is now arriving in 2022 given the high
bar set by its predecessor that probably
is for the best horizon forbidden west
as the name suggests sees eloy venturing
into the hellscape of the western united
states
which is also now in a post-apocalypse
as she continues her journey of survival
and discovery in a world overrun by
dinosaur-like robots a phrase that makes
my inner seven-year-old swoon stealth
aerobatic traversal and bow combat are
at the heart of the franchise and all
look to be making their return in full
force for the sequel we'll also
hopefully get some more answers
regarding some of the game's more
intriguing sci-fi questions raised by
its truly unique setting five years is a
long time to wait but thankfully we
don't have to wait much longer with
forbidden west coming out on february 18
2022
and with that that is our list for the
most anticipated playstation exclusives
coming in 2022 and in a few cases beyond
yet we also know that we probably missed
a few of your personal favorites so let
us know down below what you're looking
forward to in the new year besides
obviously morbius because come on we're
all excited for that right right come on
jared leto doing his weird jared leto
stuff i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morbius also don't forget to subscribe
to gamespot so you don't miss our other
list and coverage of upcoming games with
that said have a wonderful rest of your
2021 and live long and prosper